♪
>> Tucker: SO INFLATION IS
HIGHER THAN IT'S BEEN IN
GENERATIONS, MAYBE EVER
DEPENDING HOW YOU MEASURE IT SO
JOE BIDEN'S RESPONSES HE WILL
PRINT A LOT MORE MONEY AND SEND
IT TO THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE.
>> TODAY I'M ANNOUNCING ANOTHER
$800 MILLION TO FURTHER AUGMENT
UKRAINE'S ABILITY TO FIGHT IN
THE EAST.
THIS PACKAGE INCLUDES HEAVY
ARTILLERY WEAPONS, AND 144,000
ROUNDS OF AMMUNITION TO GO WITH
THOSE.
IT ALSO INCLUDES MORE TACTICAL
DRONES.
SOMETIMES YOU WILL SPEAK SOFTLY
AND CARRY A LARGE JAVELIN
BECAUSE WE ARE CARRYING A LOT OF
THOSE AS WELL.
>> Tucker: FOR US.
IT'S NOT JUST GUNS WE ARE
SENDING, WHERE SENDING ANOTHER
HALF A BILLION TO PAY FOR THE
SALARIES OF WORKERS IN THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
THAT GOVERNMENT, SHOULD WE BE
DOING THAT?
WHAT HAPPENS ALL THESE WEAPONS
WE SENT TO UKRAINE.
ACCORDING TO CNN, WE DON'T KNOW.
THE U.S. HAS FEW WAYS TO TRACK
WEAPONRY WE SENT ACROSS THE
BORDERS OF THE WEAPONS ARE JUST
DISAPPEARING FAST.
>> THE FIRST SHIPMENT OF THE
NEW, MORE HEAVY DUTY MILITARY
ASSISTANCE FOR UKRAINE STARTED
ARRIVING IN THE REGION OVER THE
WEEKEND, BUT THERE IS ALREADY
CONCERNED THAT MORE EQUIPMENT
MAY BE NEEDED SOON.
U.S. OFFICIAL SAID THERE IS
GROWING CONCERNS ABOUT THE
AMMUNITION INVENTORY OF THE
UKRAINIANS AS IT'S EXPECTED THAT
HEAVY GROUND COMBAT WILL BE
PICKING UP IN THE COMING DAYS IN
EASTERN UKRAINE.
THE NEW ROUND OF $800 MILLION
WORTH OF SECURITY ASSISTANT
INCLUDES 18 A-LISTERS AND 40,000
ARTILLERY ROUNDS.
BUT AUTHORITIES SAY THIS COULD
BE EXTENDED AND USED IN JUST A
MATTER OF DAYS.
THE PENTAGON HAS BEEN WORKING
TRYING TO ADDRESS HOW TO ARM THE
UKRAINIANS FASTER.
>> Tucker: SO THEY'VE BEATEN
YOU INTO SUBMISSION WITH MORE
LECTURES, MEANWHILE THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS SENT MORE THAN A
BILLION DOLLARS TO UKRAINE IN
JUST THE PAST WEEK AND TODAY AS
WE TOLD YOU THE SECRETARY OF
TREASURY ANNOUNCING HALF A
BILLION TO PAY THE SELLERS OF
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT WORKERS.
SHOULDN'T WE HAVE AN AUDIT OF
FINANCES FIRST?
SHUT UP, THAT IS PRIVILEGED
INFORMATION.
A FORMER SENIOR ADVISOR OF
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IS THERE NO CONCERN, AS WE'VE
SEEN SO OFTEN IN THE PAST,
WEAPONS WE SENT AWARDS ON MY END
UP IN THE WRONG PLACES?
>> THERE IS SOME CONCERN BUT NOT
ENOUGH TO STOP THE HEMORRHAGING
OF MATERIAL INTO UKRAINE.
WITH HAD TERRIBLE PROBLEMS IN
THE PAST FOR ACCOUNTING FOR
WHERE AMMUNITION AND WEAPONS GO.
WE'VE SEEN IN SOUTHEAST ASIAN
AND IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN IT I
THINK WE CAN SAY WITH SOME
CERTAINTY THAT MANY OF THESE
WEAPONS WILL END UP IN THE HANDS
OF PEOPLE WE WOULD RATHER NEVER
SEE THEM IN.
BUT THAT ASIDE, IF YOU LISTEN TO
WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID TODAY,
HE IS CONVEYING THE IMPRESSION
THAT ANY OF THIS WILL CHANGE THE
OUTCOME.
IT WILL NOT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS
THE FINAL ANNIHILATION OF WHAT
REMAINS OF UKRAINE'S BEST FORCES
DOWN IN THE SOUTHEASTERN CORNER
OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY CAN'T CHANGE THAT.
REMEMBER, THE DISTANCE FROM
POLAND TO THE BATTLEFRONT IS
ROUGHLY THE SAME AS THE DISTANCE
BETWEEN ST. LOUIS AND
NEW YORK CITY.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO TRAIN PEOPLE,
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUSTAIN THE
EQUIPMENT AND THEN THEY'VE GOT
TO MOVE IT.
I'M AFRAID THE ONLY THING WE ARE
DOING HIS ESCALATING TENSIONS
WITH RUSSIA AND TURNING WESTERN
UKRAINE INTO A LARGE TARGET SET
FOR RUSSIAN MISSILES, ROCKETS
AND AIR STRIKES.
>> Tucker: THIS IS ALSO SAD
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE, MOSTLY THE
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS CAUGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF IT, ARE WE MAKING
LIFE BETTER FOR THEM CUSTOMER IT
SEEMS LIKE WE ARE FIGHTING FOR
THE LAST UKRAINIANS TO ME.
>> WE ARE AND I REALLY THINK THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SUPPORTING
ADVISORS BELIEVE THAT SOMEHOW OR
ANOTHER THEY ARE GOING TO ARRIVE
AT A NEGOTIATING TABLE IN THE
FUTURE WHERE THEY WILL BE ABLE
TO DICTATE TERMS TO MOSCOW, AND
THAT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND IF THERE IS NO NEGOTIATED
SETTLEMENT, THEN WESTERN UKRAINE
JUST BECOMES A FIRING RANGE, ANY
TIME SEE ANY EVIDENCE FOR
SIGNIFICANT MILITARY EQUIPMENT
SHOWS UP THEY WILL DESTROY IT
FROM A DISTANCE BECAUSE THE
RUSSIANS HAVE NEVER BEEN
INTERESTED IN CROSSING THE
RIVER, THEY WERE ALWAYS
INTERESTED IN DESTROYING
UKRAINIAN FORCES.
THAT JOB IS ABOUT THROUGH, SO I
THINK THE SAD TRUTH OF THE
MATTER IS THAT THIS IS A PROXY
WAR IN WHICH WE ARE SENDING
LARGE NUMBERS OF UKRAINIANS TO
DIE WITHOUT ANY REAL HOPE THAT
WE WILL OBTAIN ANYTHING OF
IMPORTANCE.
>> Tucker: SO DEPRESSING,
ESPECIALLY AS YOU PUT IT THAT
WAY AS CLEARLY AS YOU DO.
COLONEL DOUGLAS McGREGOR,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
WE ARE MORNING AS WE TOLD YOUR
MOM TO GO TONIGHT THE
INVOLUNTARY RETIREMENT OF MIKE
WALLACE'S SON.
NO MORE LECTURES ON TV.
BUT EVEN AS WE ARE DOING THAT WE
HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT WHICH YOU
ARE GOING